[Musik]
ja ich habe mich zu dem Zeitpunkt halt
nur noch auf der Drogenhandel
konzentriert unter
drogenhandelsigsten
mit 14 auf die Schiffe Bahn und landete
mit 23 im Gefängnis heute erklärt er
über die Folgen von Jugend Kriminalität
auf
schönes Gefühl
aber ich erzähle es immer nur halt auch
gern zum über den Menschen der junge
Mann zu zeigen dass das der falsche Weg
ist
[Musik]
vor einem aufklärungseinsatz zusammen
mit der Geschäftsführerin des Vereins
Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen und seinem
Hund Miele das Schulhaus von Rohrbachs
freiensteinteufen kennt Ilias
hier zur Schule gegangen doch seine
Schulzeit endete in der ersten Oberstufe
mit einem
rausschmissstand
reflektiert
ihren Anfang und sie endete im Gefängnis
ich glaube das ist so
guten Morgen
Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen
vor dem Projekt der elias-schule
ja ich bin der 20 jetzt noch
glücklich und froh dass ich mit meiner
30 Jahren
das erzähle ich Euch im heutigen Morgen
und
wettermäßigem Cannabiskonsum
richtige Schuhe mitnehmen
auch finanzieren ich weiß nicht können
wir Tasche
sehr schön für eure Eltern
langsam aber sicher Abdriften in der
Schule
verschlagen worden und bin schon seit
Oberstufe Schuhe Abschluss
[Musik]
seit 4 Jahren ist Elias frei im Fuß und
lebt seither in einer kleinen
Mietwohnung
[Musik]
seine Delikte Haus Friedensbruch Drohung
Verstoß gegen das Betäubungsmittelgesetz
Sachbeschädigung
Banden und gewerbsmäßiger Diebstahl
drei Jahre saß er dafür in der
Justizvollzugsanstalt per Schweiz
[Musik]
heute arbeitet Jury in einem 80% Pensum
für den Verein Gefangene helfen
Jugendlichen
aber sie hängt wenig Sachen
gefängnisraum
und später nicht kaufte
[Musik]
dem Heimen im Gefängnis da bin ich doch
zu hygienisch und darum ist Betten das
Auffangen
Occasion oder eine Geschenk bekommen
natürlich
das ganze finanzieren
Berg von über 100000 Franken den ihr
noch mindestens 10 Jahre lang abbezahlen
muss schneller schuldenfrei wäre er ohne
seinen Straßen und Michelle aus Sizilien
doch ein Leben ohne Miele ist für Jury
undenkbar einfach
ja
nicht ganz so viel ich kann schon
führe mich nicht in Versuchung hat sich
Jury auf seine beiden Hände tätowiert
denn die Versuchung lauert überall
ganz am Anfang
mit mir
los die Leute eigentlich sind mir nicht
sagen gar nicht erst
ich gar nicht ich muss vor allen Dingen
einfach weg und nur so komme
so viel
gemacht
[Musik]
15:40 Uhr so viel passiert
im ganzen Land oder und jetzt macht er
mir irgendwann macht sie mir so
unaufspitze mit dem Gefängnis mit
und zum Glück auch irgendwann irgendwann
die falschen Freunde
was folgte war eine ruinierte Jugend
Heimaufenthalte Pflegefamilien Leben auf
der Kurve und in jugendgefängnisse in
über 20 Institutionen lebte Schuhe bis
zu seinem 18 Lebensjahr
was läuft mit euch falsch kann mich
verraten verlassen gefühlt vor allem mit
einer Familie Mitglieder wie auch
versuchte erwachsene Personen und haben
das heftigste
Pädagoge und Gegner
gesagt
machen
am Anfang seiner Tätigkeit im Verein
habe er jeden Abend zu Hause geweint
erinnert sich schon Schuld und
Schamgefühle plagten den ehemaligen
Häftling eine Psychotherapie ist deshalb
unabdingbare Bestandteil seiner Arbeit
im Verein Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen
trotzdem die Aufarbeitung des Erlebten
bleibt schmerzhaft
[Musik]
sind beides
wo ich mich damit selber zum Opfer
gemacht habe
jedes Kind ist schlussendliches Opfer 19
Familie Systeme funktioniert das ist
einfach Fakt oder das
Kind kann nicht überlegen sind
für das verantwortlich also wenn man
will kann
aber im Endeffekt ruf mich erwachsen
werden 14 15
mit 15 Jahren wurde Elias
Basel eingewiesen eine
durchgangsinstitution für männliche
Jugendliche
[Musik]
wir haben den Termin mit der Frau Denz
hallo
der institutionsleiterin begegnet schury
heute auf Augenhöhe eine Kehrtwende wie
er sie in den letzten Jahren durchlaufen
hat hätte mir niemand zugetraut
schwieriger
[Musik]
die eine ganze Belastungen die wir sind
wie viel der auch oder ich glaube so
dass was er sich jetzt mal als belastend
älteren Oma sind und mir hätte
geschlossenen Abteilung
untergebracht
verändert hat sich hier wenig und die
Ohnmachtsgefühle überwältigen
das ist mein Liebling
sspiel
e verkratzt
ja was hängt sie denn so einer wohl
diese Rinne
warum ich Musik gesperrt
und kann einfach eigentlich
Jugendkriminalität verläuft in Wellen
erzählt mir Annette Denz seit 2016 ist
sie wieder am steigen und die Täter
werden immer jünger
12-jährige du und das der hat auch schon
diverse Raub gemacht das ist jetzt nicht
der erste schon die und
ja in dem Alter ist es aus meiner
Erfahrung noch schwieriger als
intervenieren weil das ist alles nur
spannend Abenteuer und also
Gleichgültigkeit und und das oder das
auch nicht abschätzen können vor der
Konsequenz sicher in dem Alter
losprojekte wie jetzt 60 70-Jährige
was was macht man damit so Kind
gute Frage
[Musik]
also
jetzt bei uns waren weiß dass sie
Familie die Hinterhof
nicht hinterlagt sie sind ihre Kinder
auszuziehen also wo wo relativ schnell
so die Hierarchie Umkehr auch ist und
und und und und die Jungs dann bestimme
Prävention wäre bereits im Kindergarten
notwendig bei Ilias Schori gab es diese
nicht und später schaffen es alle
Sozialpädagoginnen und
Sozialpädagogen in geschlossenen und
offenen Institutionen nicht mehr ihn auf
den richtigen Weg zu bringen mit 23
landete er im Gefängnis und hier begann
seine Wandlung
ja und ich bin dann sechs Männer in
Untersuchungshaft
zu mehr als 40 Minuten verurteilt wurde
3 Jahre
unter anderem im größten
Hochsicherheitsgefängnis von der Schweiz
420 schwer verbracht
dass ich nicht oder will ich da anders
zeichnete sich aber schon vor der
Verurteilung hat
recht viel übrig oder kalt
leider gekauft
in Ausgang und auf der putzkauer und
sogar
Videos
kommen oder aber schlechte gewisse ich
dann langsam aber sicher
absolute
Schuldgefühl sind da um mich passiert
und was sag jetzt hier zu einer
opferrhode ist sogar vielleicht von
innen und das jetzt lügt und dann
Entschuldigung für das was ich gemacht
habe
mit seiner Arbeit für den Verein
Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen wohl eher
der Gesellschaft etwas zurückgeben was
er einzelnen Opfern genommen habe sagt
Elias Jury
ängstlich
ste Art und Weise zum Opfer eines
Gewaltverbrechens wurde Elias Schori hat
mit dieser Tat nichts zu tun
der Mord im Zürcher Seefeld erschütterte
2016 die Öffentlichkeit ein Insassen
frei zu pressen
das Mordopfer dura sens Sohn Marco
ich finde grundsätzlich
selber und dann die findet dann schon
der Weg es geht seit
kennenlernen weil sie von seinem
Werdegang beeindruckt war zwischen den
beiden ist eine Freundschaft entstanden
[Musik]
und
ja das lässt grüßen
im Allgemeinen
Jugendkriminalität ist kein neues
Phänomen Menschen der Linken am
allermeisten zwischen 15 und 20 Jahren
in allen Gesellschaften zu jeder Zeit es
gilt wenige Jugendliche Zeichen für
viele Straftaten verantwortlich
im Jugendalter ist es besonders
verbreitet kriminell zu sein 3,5% der
Jugendlichen sind Polizei registriert
wurden heißt das 97,5% nicht
viele junge Menschen
wissen was richtig was falsch ist und
die die hier registriert werden heißt
auch lange nicht dass dies nicht wissen
sondern sind mal mitgerissen worden
Freundesgruppen spielen eine große Rolle
im Jugendalter das wissen wir sind mit
der Kameras ausprobiert
der Großteil der jungen Menschen ist auf
einem auf einem guten Weg
und von seiner Aufklärungsarbeit für den
Verein Gefangene helfen Jugendlichen
man muss Prävention einstufen als etwas
aufwendiges Prävention funktioniert
nicht durch ein Videofilm funktioniert
nicht durch eine Stunde in der Schule wo
man über seine Biografie redet
Prävention ist etwas Dauerhaftes man
muss Kompetenzen vermitteln jungen
Menschen dass sie sich auch alternativ
verhalten können in Situationen nicht
immer gleich zuschlagen und das braucht
Zeit von daher diese Form von prävention
wird nur erreicht wenn das ein Baustein
einer eines größeren Programms ist also
das auch mal ein ehemaliger Häftling
kommt etwas erzählen aber das muss Teil
eines viel umfassenderen Kompetenz
vermittelnden Programmen
Pflanzen davon was dann noch er passiert
aber wirklich ein Intervention das würde
ich auch sagen was der Bayer gesagt hat
dass es da
beziehungsarbeiten braucht und das
gerade über den längeren Zeitpunkt das
ist aber nicht Ausgabe Gefangene helfen
Jugendlichen mit zwei anderen
was in der Familie angefangen hat und ja
glücklich bin ich eigentlich Max ich bin
relativ normal aufgewachsen da bin ich
noch gesehen
das heißt Herbert auf Italienisch und
daran ist
so böse stehend
[Musik]
das ist von sechs Kindern aufgewachsen
mehr will mir über seine Kindheit nicht
erzählen nur dass es schwierig war
schwierig ist
wir sind zu Besuch bei seiner Mutter und
seiner Schwester bei den Dreharbeiten
dort ist Elias Schule verzweifelt wütend
genervt traurig
die Kamera und die ständige
Auseinandersetzung mit seiner
schwierigen Biografie in den Schulen
setzen im Zug genau wie das Verhältnis
zu seinen Eltern
ich hätte anders gesagt
jeder hat seine
Orten Whisky so zu rebellieren
irgendwo vielleicht
Situation was ist ihres Rucksäcke ich
mag mich zum Beispiel einfach nur
erinnern dass das dass ich die ganze
Panik die haben
und ähm
ich bin undankbar ich bin wahnsinnig
dankbar wenn ich die Freunde
halt finde und mich abgelenkt auch für
die eigenen Augen wirklich der Ganztag
einfach nur träge
ich nehme es ruhig ich bin immer traurig
ich bin nicht trauriger Mensch von Natur
aus glaube nein
und ich bin erhütend trauriger Mensch
ganz ganz viele Sachen und ich kann
darüber
im Endeffekt bin ich eine traurig drüber
das ist muss man in der Familie so
entstanden ich weiß
dass ich immer Verzauberer
verantwortlich bin dafür
Ilias Betroffenheit hält auch am
nächsten Tag an bei den Dreharbeiten mit
seiner Pflegefamilie
mit 18 kam er zu Matthias Welt und
dessen Frau kurz darauf brach Elias
seine Lehre als Automechaniker ab und er
beging weitere Straftaten seine
Pflegeeltern gaben ihn trotz alledem
nicht auf das war wahrscheinlich schon
ist Rettung
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht so für mich und
Schlüsselpunkt
damals fünfklässler was mich aber so
beeindruckt hätte ich dir Tatsache dass
du damals auf dem Areal vom von der
Schule so was
wir sollten Entschuldigung
zwei in Kontakt treten
wo mir ganz ganz viel gelernt hat
privat
mache
[Musik]
ohne seine Pflegefamilie hätte er den
Weg aus der Kriminalität nicht geschafft
doch dieser Weg bleibt hart und steinig
sagt mir Elias Jury gepflastet mit
Schuldgefühlen und Scham aber ein zurück
komme für ihn nicht in Frage
[Musik]